what I've done is I've started off and
you can see as as we mentioned before
the first thing you got to do is get
these talking to each other in polar
form without pull the form you're
starting up the creek without a partner
you can't use Tamar vestir it's not
going to help you okay so that's why the
first thing I've done after describing
the number in polar form I've said okay
well that's that in polar form using the
bhangra sarah and this over here is a 16
root 3 + 69 in polar form okay now you
can see where I got this I like to draw
myself a little triangle over here you
can see there's my 16 root 3 there's the
real part and this is my 16 I there's
the imaginary part and this is the
triangle you get right so hopefully you
sort of recognize your life oh ok this
is the arm this is the 1 2 root 3
triangle so there's there's all your
geometry so PI on six is the argument
you're interested in okay now at this
next point I noticed a lot of you right
you got to this and then you thought
okay I know I remember where we spent
most our effort last time you get two
solutions out of this and then you take
those two solutions you see how they
copy forward or like my fame and then
you proceed it's a problem with that
though there are two halves to this is
the cosine part and then there's the
sign part and really imaginary
components now what is cosplay on six
what these cause politics come on think
exactly equals this postulate this is
root 3 on 2 right route around two so
I'm root 3 is about 1.7 route 302 you
might recognize your calculator will
tell you is your point 86 something
rather so this is cosine right 0.86 is
like somewhere up here right do you
agree with that because the amplitude of
cosine is one so that's why I'm putting
this I think that's pretty fair from
route 302 and you can see there are two
solutions right the first solution
naturally is politics you know this
other solution of here what is this
by the way well this is too high right
at the end and you can see the symmetry
other write cosine is symmetrical so if
you have forward part 6 to get to here
then it should be so close this is to
play which is 1206 so if you go back one
that's going to be 11 provinces yeah now
there are two solutions politics urban
politics why then you do the sign bit
right now you're doing sci fi three
equals sign politics aside politics is
about a half right so where are the
solutions on this is this one plan 6 and
then the other solution is look at the
geometry of it ok you went forward he
are my pilot seat yeah that's very good
you move from here which is pi backwards
the same distance which lands you in 5
pi/6 ok so I know it's a bit higher
because you're in radians about nothing
but look look I need solutions to both
of these both right so what happens to
this guy these are done you disregard
him because he's not shared by this and
in the same way this also gets
disregarded because he's not shared by
that so you've got one solution that
matters all right which is pilot
politics but but this graph is just one
part of the graph it goes on forever
right so have a look how did I get to
this next angle what did I do from plan
6 213 pile on six it has a period of 2
hype so I went forward to PI I got to
hear I will form another 2 pi and then I
kept going how many solutions that I
write down I wrote down six because I
knew five of them would matter and the
sixth one you can see when you divide
through by five to solve for theta
that's what you're doing after all right
when you divide the last one that I've
written down you're like hey hold on a
second you can subtract to play from
that and get back to this do you see it
do you see what's going on so your last
solution is just an extra copy it's just
a duplicate so you don't need to worry
about it so that's why I've got one two
three four five solutions
from the first five answers do you see
that you can also see why this is the
reason that I don't keep on going
backwards into the negative what would
be the answer before this one it's going
to be negative 11 PI on faith isn't it
because it be negative 11 PI on 6/5 but
negative 11 pi is the same as 49 pie do
you see that right because they're going
to add up to touch your pie so there are
my solutions and you can see you didn't
even ask you to do this but this is what
the solutions look like this I've drawn
them okay so I've done my best to do
that little angle here's my pile on 30
okay here's my next one which is now how
far have I gone 72 to greens which I
happen to know is 2 pi or five now it's
not because I'm so awesome at conversion
that I know it's to pilot 5 what is 2 pi
what's the definition of too high it's a
hole it's a whole revolution right and
look I know there's going to be one two
three four five parts that I'm spacing
them out do you see that okay so
therefore it's two pi 2 / 5 which
happens to be 70 degrees okay so as a
conclusion because I hope you've got
your solutions to the 6th roots of unity
and then you look at this here's my
conclusion that maybe you want right
down hope you can read that I've written
written a bit small okay sorry the nth
roots like the sixth roots or the fifth
roots or the 23rd roots the entrance of
any complex number in polar form right
there equally spaced around the
circumference of a circle you've seen
that many times like there it is right
there equally spaced around the circle
has a center at the origin it has a
radius of what's the radius of this one
the radius of this the particular circle
I'm looking at right now is 22 because
when you multiply this by itself five
times what happens to the modulus it's
going to get raised to the fifth power
which is 32 that's the modules of
mother you started with that 16 was it
16 root 3 plus 60 night during that
right so doing it five times gets you to
that modulus and so too is important
because it's the fifth root of 32 that's
on the nth root of Ireland right the
fifth root of 32 and they are separated
by an angle of 2 pi on em in our first
example that was 2 pi on 6 which of
course was pipe on three but this time
it's two pi 15 which is 17